[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
premier set une culture de l'année 2010
est tout de suite le sommaire de ce
mercredi 4 janvier un magazine
spécialement consacré à la deuxième
partie de saison des salle culturelle de
saint quentin en yvelines alors pour la
batterie de huy en course au sort à
nouveau de déclic son du rock du
classique de la musique française donc
endurer y ait au scarabée de la verrière
ce sera un voyage à travers le monde
avec de la musique afro américaine et du
côté du théâtre national de saint
quentin en yvelines dont reprendre de la
tradition au presque suis curieuse
propose une nouvelle adaptation du
célèbre conte le petit chaperon rouge a
alors dans chaque set une culture en
avait l'habitude on vous propose les
rendez vous à ne pas manquer sur saint
quentin en yvelines
deux salles de l'agglomération font
elles des demi saison alors je vous
propose de nous intéresser
principalement à elle pour découvrir
leur programmation
on débute avec la batterie de guyancourt
pour l'année 2010 est ce sera éclectique
regardez l'éclectisme maîtres mots de la
batterie la salle guyancourt toise
propose pour sa deuxième partie de
saison il vingtaine de dates de nombreux
styles musicaux avec bien sûr du rock
on a beaucoup de brokers on a des
suisses pour que sa vie animale
le jour à la fiche donc le 10 mars avec
les anime l on retrouvera les
psychotiques manque ce qui avait été
découvert lors du dernier festival rock
en seine on aura également en rock on va
dire les plus anciens avec les wampas
qui vont sortir leur album là début 2010
est donc après 30 ans de carrière voilà
je viens enfin c'est toujours aussi
aussi dynamiques sur scène
[Musique]
nous entendons du classique du hip hop
de la musique française mais aussi de la
musique d' union africaine
particulièrement et kubel la batterie
c'est un mélange d'artistes
internationaux mais aussi locaux et des
têtes d'affiché notamment pour les
amateurs de reggae on aura aussi
l'honneur d'accueillir une des légendes
vivantes delà de la période des années
du reggae jamaïcain en la personne de
pablo moses qui revient donc avec un
nouvel album lui aussi qui a été produit
par harrison stafford le chanteur de
groundation groupe de reggae californie
qui est venu ici en octobre à guyancourt
les concerts reprennent le 15 janvier
une année festive 2017 marquera les 10
ans de la batterie autres salles le
scarabée à la verrière le début de
saison 2016 2017 a été marquée par le
concert de thomas fersen en ouverture
mais aussi le week-end play for humanity
en hommage aux victimes des attentats du
13 novembre 2015
si la première partie de la saison était
placée sous le signe de la musique
française la deuxième elle sera plus
orienté vers la musique du monde
regardez
[Musique]
ah ah
get up pour cette année 2010 est le
scarabée invite à se lever se lever au
son de la musique afro-américaine dans
toute la ville pour tous les publics et
un concert pour débuter l'année
c'est un projet qui est né dans nos
têtes d'une envie de de partir de
changer un petit peu de la chanson
française
même si on aime beaucoup ça et de partir
un peu à la découverte d'un autre
continent
et puis c'est aussi un moyen d'aborder
plein d'autres questions puisque
l'histoire de cette musique elle est
vraiment lié à l'évolution de la société
américaine
à la question des droits civiques de
l'égalité des droits pour tous et ça
c'était vraiment un sujet qui nous
tenait à coeur
un voyage à travers le monde aussi avec
l'orchestré national de barbès le 25
février
le groupe franco algérien fêtera ses 20
ans ou encore une soirée pour la saint
patrick la fête irlandaise
c'est un des grands rendez vous de
l'année qui est très attendu par notre
public donc là le vendredi 17 mars on
aura un concert de musique celtique avec
le groupe les salles tic qui vont
visiter un peu tout le répertoire de les
causes du pays de galles à la bretagne
avec un show après l'arrivée
le scarabée mettra aussi à l'honneur des
artistes locaux
la saison reprend dès le 28 janvier du
côté du théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la saison 2
recrute dès aujourd'hui mercredi 4
janvier les spectateurs sont invités à
se plonger dans une histoire qu'on
connaît tous
celle du petit chaperon rouge la
compagnie québécoise cas public propose
un spectacle à vivre en famille dès
l'âge de deux ans le reportage est
réalisé avec alice deschamps une petite
fille en rouge comme dans le conte bien
connu mais trois mais cholet suis
curieuse est une très libre adaptation
du petit chaperon rouge qui nous plonge
dans nos peurs enfantines
le but est d'essayer de créer car même
un climat qui était pas ce que j'appelle
mon film d'horreur pour enfants mais le
christ a fait à cette tension pour jouer
avec les tensions et relâchement du
récit c'est le premier petit livre qu'on
m'a offert quand j'étais enfant j'avais
deux ans c'est une histoire qui était
une matière en fait c'est plus une
matière qu'une histoire
je me sentais moins besoin de raconter
que je ça me permettait de les bloquer
une danse rapide énergique et plein de
poésie une pièce courte pour les plus
petits mais non dénué de virtuosité ne
pas faire le compromis d'une danse ont
rabaissé peut-être forme et d'amoindrir
le niveau de danse parce qu'on voudrait
plaire ou insérer des formes qui
faciliterait donc on est dans une très
grande exigence au niveau de la danse ce
qui nous permet de conduire quand même
je pense de manière efficace notre récit
d'abord une très très grande poésie mais
aussi que les adultes ou les enfants
parce que je pense que c'est d'abord
tout public qu'on fait d'eux surtout
avec la conscience qu'ils ont vu quelque
chose de très clair suite curieuse un
gros coffre à jouets où chacun pioche ce
dont il a envie à partager en famille
et si vous avez envie de prolonger ses
suites curieuse une heure d'atelier avec
les danseurs de la compagnie ça se passe
samedi 7 janvier de 14 heures à 15
heures pour les bédéphiles un événement
rien que pour vous sur l'agglomération
beaunoise sky du 4 janvier au 18 février
plus d'un mois d'animations autour de la
bd
une manière de faire un clin d'oeil au
festival d'angoulême qui lui se
déroulera du 26 au 29 janvier pour le
programme une exposition des ateliers
des rencontres et un temps fort
je laisse julien omnes vous le présenter
on a une jeune auteur qui s'appelle alex
qui va venir dans cinq équipements qui
va contribuer à co créé avec les usagers
une bande dessinée sur l'ensemble du
réseau pour ça c'est notre gros temps
fort ça commence le 14 janvier à
elancourt et âme à nice on enchaîne le
21 on à la conclusion le 18 février
des propos recueillis par wilfrid richy
lors du 7-8 les invités du mardi 3
janvier l'intégralité de l'entretien est
à retrouver sur notre site internet
on passe maintenant à notre page cinéma
et si vous vous laissez tenter par une
toile à cette semaine le coup de coeur
de cinéma c'est celui de cyril haddad de
l'espace philippe noiret au pied souvent
à écouter cette semaine notre coup de
coeur et le film joyeux bordel avec
deliver aniston à la tête de
l'entreprise familiale
carole menace de fermer la branche
dirigé par son frère fêtards et son
équipe de bras cassés qui pense plus à
s'éclater qu'à faire des bénéfices
il n'en fallait pas plus à ce dernier
pour qu'il leur fixe une ultime mission
organisée dans les bureaux une soirée de
noël totalement épique et hors normes
afin d'impressionner un de leurs plus
gros clients convoité est signé un
contrat qui pourrait sauver leur boulot
oh pardon
noël joyeux bordel s'inscrit dans la
ligne droite des meilleures comédies du
genre comme projet x ou very bad trip
des répliques fusent
la réalisation est bien rythmé notamment
grâce à son casting jennifer aniston est
parfaite en patronne intraitable elle
incarne enfin le rôle d'une peau de
vache
quant aux autres comédiens ils sont eux
aussi impeccable de précisions le
spectateur à tout pour s'éclater et en
sortit racontant joyeux bordel est à
découvrir en cette rentrée 2010 est à
l'espace philippe noiret
[Musique]
et comme chaque semaine des rendez vous
à noter dans vos agendas on débute avec
un concert de jazz la chanteuse sara
lazarus rend hommage à cole porter
george gershwin ou encore richard rogers
des standards américains à découvrir au
théâtre national
on reste au théâtre mais cette fois
c'est une exposition les itinéraires
politique vous plongent eux dans la
créativité du peuple minutes
du côté de coignières la salle alphonse
daudet redémarre sa saison avec du
théâtre catherine jacob incarne madame
une femme qui est reconnu trois guerres
beaucoup d'hommes et qui est aussi
mauvaise mère une mauvaise fille nommée
épouse
regardez cet extrait qui le disent
godiche jean bart lapointe je ne
connaissais que le clivage c'est pas
quelque chose qui sert la ville le
jardin du luxembourg ça me rappelait un
peu la campagne
donc faut lui rendre justice à londres
eut au plumard c'était un virtuose une
baguette surdimensionnés en plus parce
qu'un obus de 75
la vraie manivelle à faire voir les
étoiles
j'avais misé d'emblée sur le bon numéro
un intrépide doublé d'un infatigable
on se quitte sur un dernier extrait
extrait celui d'une comédie musicale
l'histoire d'irma la douce est à
découvrir ce samedi au théâtre espace
coluche deux plaisirs un spectacle
mêlant donc du théâtre de la chanson et
de la danse avec lorànt deutsch et
nicole croisille le 7-8 culture est
maintenant terminée je vous remercie de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve mercredi
prochain et passer une très belle année
sur tv chez 78 l'histoire on va vous
raconter
c'est une histoire extraordinaire ya
rien a dire il ya cassé mais
yapluka sert qu'à la fermer l'art se
compteront les phrases ça fait tort à
l'extase tous ces hommes c'est juste
affreux mon amour ses métiers
aujourd'hui dans des résidences et droit
qui me fait avancer
du coup je suis bien au nord du pou ta
jolie gueule d'amour mackels à moi
[Musique]
non